uh you've uh recorded
an episode of steering into the iceberg
on your common sense program yeah that
has started a lot of conversations
it's quite moving it was quite haunting
got me a lot of angry emails
really of course i did something i
haven't done in 30 years i endorsed a
political candidate from one of the two
main parties and there were a lot of
disillusioned people because of that i
guess i didn't hear it as an endorsement
i just heard it as a
the similar flavor of conversation as
you have in in
hardcore history it's almost the
speaking about modern times
in the same voice as you speak about
when you talk about history
so it was just a a little bit of a
haunting
view of the world today
i know we were just wearing our doom
doom
let me put that right back on are you no
the
the uh i like the term doom caster uh
is is there is there um
how do we get love to win what's the way
out of this
is there some hopeful
line that we can walk to uh
to avoid something and i hate to use the
terminology but
something that looks like a civil war
not necessarily a war of force but a
a division to a level where it doesn't
any longer feel like a united
states of america with an emphasis on
united
is is there a way out i read a book
a while back i want to say george
friedman the stratfor
guy wrote it was something called the
next hundred years i think it was called
and i remember thinking um i didn't
agree with any of it and one of the
things i think he said in the book was
that you know the united states was
going to break up i'm going from memory
here he might not have said that at all
but something was stuck in my memory
about that i remember thinking
um but i i think some of the arguments
were connected to
the differences that we had and the fact
that those differences are being
exploited so we talked about media
earlier in the lack of truth and
everything
we have a media climate that is
incentivized
to take the wedges in our society and
make them
wider and there's no countervailing
force
to do the opposite or to help to you
know so um
there was a famous uh memo
from a group called project for a new
american century and they took it down
but the wayback machine online
still has it and it happened before 911
spawned all kind of conspiracy theories
because
it was saying something to the effect of
and i'm really paraphrasing here but you
know that the united states needs
another pearl harbor type event
because those galvanize a country that
without those kinds of events
periodically
is naturally geared towards pulling
itself apart
and it's those periodic events that act
as the countervailing force that
otherwise is not there
if that's true then we are naturally
inclined
towards pulling ourselves apart so to
have a media
environment that makes money off
widening those divisions uh which we do
i mean
i was in talk radio and and it it has
those people the people that used to
scream at me because i wouldn't do it
but i mean we would have these terrible
conversations after every broadcast
where i'd be in there with the program
director and they're yelling at me
about heat heat was the worthy create
more heat well what is heat
right heat is division right and they
want the heat not because
they're political they're not
republicans or
or democrats either they're we want
listeners and we want engagement and
involvement
and because of the constructs of the
format you don't have a lot of time to
get it so you can't have me giving you
like on a podcast
an hour and a half or two hours where we
build a logical argument
and you're with me the whole way your
audience is changing every 15 minutes
so whatever points you make to create
interest and intrigue
and engagement have to be knee-jerk
right now
things they told me once that the
audience has to know where you stand on
every single issue within five minutes
of turning on your show
in other words you have to be part of a
of a linear
set of political beliefs so that if you
feel a
about subject a then you must feel d
about subject d
and i don't even need to hear your
opinion on it because if you feel that
way about a you're going to feel that
way about d
this is a system that is designed to
pull us apart for
profit but not because they want to pull
us apart
right it's a byproduct of the prophet
that's one little example of of
50 examples in our society that work in
that same
fashion so what that project for a new
american century document was saying is
that
we're naturally inclined towards
disunity and without
things to occasionally ratchet the unity
back up again
so that we can start from the baseline
again and then pull ourselves apart till
the next pearl harbor
that you'll pull yourself apart which i
think was i think
that's what the george friedman book was
saying that i disagreed with so much at
the time
um so in answer to your question about
civil wars
we can't have the same kind of civil war
because we don't have a geographical
division that's as clear-cut as the one
we had before right you had a basically
north south line and some border states
it was set up for that kind of a split
now we're divided within communities
within families
within gerrymandered voting districts
and precincts
right so you can't disengage
we're stuck with each other so if
there's a civil war now
for lack of a better word what it might
seem like
is the late 1960s early 1970s where you
had
the bombings and you know let's call it
domestic terrorism and things like that
because that
that would seem to be something that
once again you don't even need a large
chunk of the country pulling apart
percent of people who think it's it's
the end times
can do the damage just like we talked
about terrorism before
and a can of gas and a big lighter i've
lived in a bunch of places and i won't
give anybody ideas where a can of gas
and a bic lighter
would take a thousand houses down before
you could blink
yeah right um that terrorist doesn't
have to be
from the middle east doesn't have to
have some sort of a fundamentalist
religious agenda
it could just be somebody really pissed
off about the election results
so once again if we're playing an odds
game here
everybody has to behave for this to work
right
only a few people have to misbehave for
this thing to go sideways and remember
for every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
so you don't even have to have those
people doing all these things all they
have to do is start
retribution cycle and there's an
escalation yes and it go
and it creates a momentum of its own
which leads fundamentally if you follow
the chain of events down there
to some form of dictatorial government
as the only way to
create stability right you want to
destroy the republic and have a dictator
that's how you do
and there are parallels to nazi germany
the burning of the reichstag that you
know blah blah blah
i'm the doom caster again well and some
of it could be
manufactured by the those seeking
authoritarian powers
like the reichstag fire was or the
polish soldiers that fired over the
border before the invasion in 1939
uh to fight the uh the devil's advocate
was an angel's advocate
uh i would say just as our conversation
about elon
it feels like individuals have power to
unite us
to to be that force of unity so
uh you mentioned the media i think
you're one of the
great podcasters in history joe rogan is
a
like a long form whatever it's not
podcasting it's actually
whatever the very infrequent is what it
is no matter what it is
but the basic process of it is you go
deep and you stay deep
and the listener stays with you for a
long time so
i i'm just looking at the numbers like
we're almost three hours in
and i uh from previous episodes i can
tell you that
about 300 000 people are still listening
to the sound of our voice
three hours in so usually 300 to 500 000
people listen and they too
congratulations by the way that's
wonderful
joe rogan is what like 10 times that and
so
he has power
to unite uh you have power to unite
there's a few
people with voices that it feels like
they have power to unite
even if you if you quote unquote endorse
a candidate and so on
there's still it feels to me that
speaking of i don't want to keep saying
love but it's
love and maybe unity more practically
speaking
that like sanity that
like respect for those you don't agree
with or don't understand
uh so empathy well
just a few voices of those can help us
avoid
the really importantly not avoid the
singular events like you said
of somebody starting a fire and so on
but avoid
the escalation of it the
preparedness of the populace to escalate
those events to yeah to to turn a
singular event
and a single riot or a shooting or
like even something much more dramatic
than that to turn that into something
that creates like ripples that grow
as opposed to ripples that fade away and
so like
i would like to put responsibility on
somebody like you
and uh on me in some small way and joe
being cognizant of the fact
that a lot of very destructive things
might happen in november
and a few voices can save us is the
feeling i have
not by saying who you should vote for or
any of that kind of stuff
but really by being the the the voice of
calm that like calms
the the seas from or whatever the
analogy is from boiling up
because i i truly am worried about
this is the first time this year when i
i sometimes i somehow have felt that the
american project will go on forever
that when i came to this country i just
believed and i still think i'm young but
like
you know i have a dream of creating a
company
that will do a lot of good for the world
and
i thought that america is the beacon of
hope for the world
and the ideas of freedom but also the
idea of empowering companies that can do
some good for the world
and i'm just worried about this america
that filled me a kid that came from
our family came from nothing and from
you know russia as it was soviet union
as it was to be
able to do anything in this new country
i'm just worried about it and it feels
like a few people
can still keep this project going
like people like elon people like joe
uh is there
do you have a bit of that hope i'm
watching this experiment
with social media right now and i don't
even mean social media really expand
that out to
um i mean i feel like we're all guinea
pigs right now watching you know i have
two kids and just watching and there's a
three year space between the two of them
one's 18 the other is 15.
and just you know in when i was a kid a
person who was 18 and 15 would not be
that different just three years
difference more maturity but their life
experiences you would easily classify
those two people as being in the same
generation
now because of the speed of
technological change
there is a vast difference between my 18
year old and my
15 year old and not in a maturity
question just in what apps they use
how they relate to each other how they
deal with their peers
their social skills all those kinds of
things where you turn around and go
this is uncharted territory we've never
been here so it's going to be
interesting to see what effect that has
on society now as that relates to your
question
the most upsetting part about all that
is reading how people treat each other
online and you know there's lots of
theories about this the fact
that some of it is just for trolling
laughs that some of it is just people
are not
interacting face to face so they feel
free to treat each other that way
um and i of course i'm trying to figure
out
how how if this is how we have
always been as people right we've always
been this way but we've never had the
means to post our feelings
publicly about it or if the environment
and the social media and everything else
has provided a
change and changed us into something
else
um either way when one reads
how we treat one another and the
horrible things we say about one another
online
which seems like it shouldn't be that
big of deal they're just word
but they have a cumulative effect i mean
when you uh i was reading um
meghan markle who i don't know a lot
about because it's it's too much of the
pop side of culture for me to pay
but i read a story the other day where
she was talking about the abuse she took
online
and how incredibly overwhelming it was
and how many people were doing it
and you think to yourself okay this is
something that people
who are in positions of what you were
discussing earlier never had to deal
with
let me ask you something and boy this is
the ultimate doom caster thing of all
time to say
when you think of historical figures
that push
things like love and
peace and um and and creating bridges
between
enemies when you think of how what
happened to those
people first of all they're very
dangerous every society in the world has
a better time easier time dealing with
violence and things like that than they
do
non-violence is really difficult for
governments to deal with for example
what happens to gandhi and jesus and
martin luther king and you think about
all those people right
when they're that day it's it's ironic
isn't it that these people who push for
peaceful solutions are so often killed
but it's because they're effective and
when they're
killed the effectiveness is diminished
why are they killed because they're
effective and and the only way to stop
them is to eliminate them because
they're charismatic leaders who don't
come around every day and if you
eliminate them from the scene
the odds are you're not going to get
another one for a while i guess what i'm
saying is the very things you're talking
about which would have the effect you
think it would right they would
destabilize systems
in a way that most of us would consider
positive but those systems have a way of
protecting themselves
right and so i i feel like
history shows see history is pretty
pessimistic i think by and large
um if only because we can find so many
examples that just sound passive
but i feel like people who are dangerous
to the way
things are tend to be removed
yes but there's two things to say i feel
like you're right
that history i feel like
the ripples that love leaves in history
are less obvious to detect but are
actually more
transformational like one could make a
case about i mean if you want to talk
about the
the long-term value of a jesus a gandhi
yes those people's ripples are still
affecting people today i agree
and that's you feel those ripples
through the general
improvement of the quality of life that
we see in throughout the generations
like you feel the ripples i'll go along
with you on that
okay but i would even if that's not true
now i tend to believe
that and by the way the the company that
i'm
working on is a competitor is exactly
attacking this which is
a competitor to twitter i think i can
build a better twitter as a first step
there's a longer story in there i think
a three-year-old child could build it
better and that this is not to denigrate
you
i'm sure yours would be better than a
three-year-old but twitter is so and
listen
facebook too they're they're really
awful platforms for intellectual
discussion and meaningful discussion
but and i'm on it so let me just say i'm
part of the problem we're new to this so
it's not it wasn't obvious at the time
how to do it it's
now you agree and now a three-year-old
can i do
i i tend to believe that we live in a
time
where the tools that people that are
interested
in providing love like the weapons
of love are much more powerful
so like the one nice thing about
technology
is it allows anyone to build a company
that's more powerful than any government
so that could be very destructive
but it could be also very positive
and that's i tend to believe that
somebody like elon that wants to do good
for the world
somebody like me and many like me could
have
more power than any one government to
uh and by power i mean the power to
affect change
which is different from government
government and i don't mean to interrupt
you but i'll forget my train of thought
i'm getting
old but i mean how do you deal with the
fact that already
governments who are afraid of this are
walling off their own internet systems
as a way to create
firewalls simply to prevent you from
doing what you're talking about
in other words if you know there's an
old line that if voting really changed
anything they'd never allow it
if if love through a modern day
successor to twitter would really do
what you wanted to do
and this would destabilize governments
do you think that governments
would would take counter measures to
squash
that love before it got too dangerous
there's several answers
one first of all i don't actually to
push back on something you said earlier
i don't think love is as much of an
enemy of the state
as as one would think different states
have different views
i i think the
states want power and i don't always
think that
love is in tension with power
like i think and and and
i think it's not just about love it's
about rationality it's reason
it's empathy all of those things i don't
necessarily think there always
have to be by definition in conflict
with each other
so that's one sense is i feel like
basically you can trojan horse love into
behind behind uh but you have to be good
at it this is the thing
is you have to be conscious of the way
these states think
so the fact that china banned certain
services and so on
that means the the companies weren't
eloquent
whoever the companies are weren't
actually good
at infiltrating like
i think isn't that a song like love is a
battlefield
i think it's all a cat editor yeah it's
all a game
and you have to be good at the game and
just like elon we said
you know with tesla and saving the
environment
i mean that's not just by getting on a
stage and saying it's important to save
the environment
is by building a product that
people can't help but love and then
convincing hollywood stars to love it
like
there's there's a game to be played okay
so let me let me build on that because i
i think there's a way to see this i
think you're right and so uh it has to
do with a story about the 1960s
in the vast scheme of things the 1960s
looks like a revival of neo-romantic
ideas right uh i had a buddy of mine
several years well
two decades older than i was who was uh
in the 60s went to the protest did all
those kind of things
and we were talking about it and i was
romanticizing it and he said don't
romanticize you guys let me tell you
most of the people that went to those
protests and did all those things
all they were there was to meet girls
and have a good time and you know it was
it wasn't so
but it became
in vogue to have all in other words
let's talk about your empathy and love
you're never gonna in my opinion grab
that great mass of people that are only
in it for them
they're interested in whatever but if
meeting
girls for a young teenage guy requires
you to
feign empathy requires you to read
deeper subjects because that's what
people are into
you can almost as as a silly way to be
trendy you could make maybe
empathy trendy love trendy solutions
that
that are the opposite of that um the
kind of things that people
inherently will not put up with you in
other words
the possibility exists to change the
zeitgeist
yes and reorient it in a way that even
if most of the people aren't serious
about it
the results are the same does that make
sense absolutely
okay okay so we've found a meeting of
the month yeah
yeah exactly creating creating
incentives that uh
that encourage the best and the most
beautiful
aspects of our will it all boils down to
meeting girls and boys
once again you're getting to the bottom
of the evolutionary motivations and
you're always on safe ground when you do
that yeah
you